I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to another
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
be doing one of my Fiverr gigs is where
review a website and give some advice
for the website owner so this one came
in for my modern web com that we're
going to check out and says please
review of someone who is looking for a
website designer so let's check out the
site and see what kind of feedback we
can give so I'm pretending that I am an
entrepreneur looking for a new website
and I happened upon this site here so my
first thought is it looks professional
which is great from hiring a web site
designer obviously want them to have a
professional website so i can rest
assured that i'm going to have a
professional website as well I love this
hire us here it's a clear call to action
I'm assuming that's gonna be on every
page the call us today is great to a
1-800 number great to have on there it
shows it it's a real development shop a
lot of times there's tons of these
companies that set up their online only
there's no way to actually you know make
a phone call and get a hold of somebody
so this shows a little bit more
credibility and just adds a little bit
more trust factor that I know what I'm
on a real website the logo is okay you
know for somebody who's in web design
I'd probably expect something a little
less you know stock photography so you
might want to improve on that a little
bit but overall looks pretty
professional it scrolls through these
five things which is great the first one
is weekly web sites to get results with
the higher rested a call to action this
is great and I'm assuming these are your
clients it'd be great to see some
testimonials so you know maybe classic
polo had some amazing results by using
you instead of another website design
company and you can have you know
picture of their CEO and saying we love
the mind modern web guys they did an
awesome job or something like that or if
they can have some kind of numbers in
there our sales grew fifty percent after
using them testimonials again go a long
way to be able to add credibility to the
business so this is great it's good to
show that the portfolio and that's going
to be something that clients will
definitely look for is you know have you
done something that look
nice thats related to my industry but
then again if you can have some kind of
testimonials on here it be that a lot
more credibility to your business so
Alexa mobile mobile apps is great a lot
of companies considering getting into
mobile so it's good to show that here we
are worldwide so this might be a little
confusing so you're showing a map of the
u.s. maybe if i zoom out I'll see more
so no okay so you're mostly in u.s. it's
great and it looks like you're centered
kind of around Missouri which is awesome
I don't know if this this hurts you
helps you sir I think it might actually
damage you to say that your world wide
and then you have we almost your clients
just send it around Missouri I probably
take that off I don't think people care
too much about it and it doesn't really
add a lot of value to people who are
visiting it and it may hurt you to say
you're worldwide and you only have a
handful of clients kind of all centered
around Missouri so I might want to take
that one off the next thing I look for
as an entrepreneur is ok it looks like a
nice design know they can kind of do
what I'm hoping they can do I want to
learn a little bit more about you so I'd
be looking for an about my modern web I
don't see that anywhere I don't seen
about up top so let's scroll maybe
there's something here so who is my
modern web ok great full service website
design internet marketing firm so click
learn more and that's going to take me
to the services page so that's great to
show your services one thing I notice
here is I'm on the services page at the
top but it says features here you know
you probably want to call that services
again features doesn't really make sense
from a customer point of view coming to
a pages as features if you could say
services but I want to learn more about
you not necessarily your features so I
said to learn more about your business
maybe there's something else who is my
modern web so again you know full
service website design and internet
marketing firm learn more where does
that take me back to the homepage ok so
you have the same text on two different
pages that just bounced between each
other I'd probably you don't fix that
and also create a page that talks about
who you are like who's the founder how
long you been in business have a picture
of who you guys are even if
a small shop one-person show your face
you know nice smiling picture I want to
see who the people are behind the
business because again there's a lot of
these fraud shops that are set up and
I'm concerned about giving my money to
somebody especially someone who's not
local or can't meet face-to-face so I'd
like to see a picture of them somewhere
so I definitely include that somewhere
on there let's go back to the services
page and see what other feedback and
kind of give on it I'm expecting you do
I mean these main things worked at
design sir search engine in social media
that's kind of what everybody's going to
be pitching but let's load up each one
and see what what you're talking about
in each one of these again this is kind
of standard package that I would expect
from any kind of website development
shop so short description okay let's see
what's on the next one SEO very short
description good you get us into Google
Places social media another very short
description I don't think you gonna win
clients on this you got to be able to
show how you're different and if I'm an
entrepreneur and I'm looking at your
design services versus other companies
i'm not i'm not being loud so i
definitely add more content on here i
chose some case studies of clients
you've worked with have testimonials
have pictures of the people who have
left those testimonials with some
results and you know spice up the
content a little bit to make your
company stand out because if you go to
100 other website development companies
and let's check out their websites
they're going to have more than this so
I'd say you a little bit behind the ball
on that the design looks great but the
content here is not winning me over as
an entrepreneur one thing my pension is
still if I'm looking at social media
would check out your social media
accounts so let's see what you're doing
your twitter facebook google+ let's load
up each one and see what's happening you
want to make sure you're actually doing
it yourself so this is great you know
we've got some tweets we've got some
followers not necessarily great to have
this discrepancy and the number follower
versus following but you know you're
posting on a regular basis which is good
so you know clients can come and see
that these guys are actually
you know doing what they say they can
provide for us so it's good if I click
on here facebook so we've got a page
great you got some likes you got some
photos let's see what this one is all
about happy birthday to our CEO Jason oh
this is great so this is this is the
jason from my modern web i put this on a
web page you know friendly guy big smile
as an entrepreneur i want to learn more
about the business so I'd like to see
this picture somewhere on your website
and talk about Jason and if there's a
team how you started the business you
know what your vision is some of the
clients have worked with people like
buying from people right they don't want
to buy from a faceless corporation and
especially one that they've never heard
of before so it's an opportunity to
stand out and tell your story and and
it's great that you have you know
friendly-looking guy big smile I
definitely include this on the page
maybe without the happy birthday Jason
but otherwise I definite that it looks
good though facebook is being active
Google+ same kind of stuff so they have
some you know some some followers there
it's good they're posting on a regular
basis which is good so it's good I mean
that's something I would want to see I
are you doing social media yourself and
if you're not doing a good job yourself
you know why would I want to hire you
and that's again another big challenge
at a lot of all turns will face when
you're looking for a website design
company they promise things but they're
not doing it themselves so there's not a
lot of credibility or trust there so
that's good and it's great that you have
the pictures of the CEOs already on
there you can move over let's see what
else we've got here we look the services
is check out the blog so again another
challenge here is a lot of companies say
they have a blog and then they don't
keep it updated so let's check it out so
we gotta post today we've got a post
last week we're at a post okay so three
post in December about you know you
keeping it up which is good let's click
on the post and see what we're talking
about here nice professional design it's
broken up nicely with you know big
category headlines here so it's easy to
read it's great call to action is good
you know comments it could be could be a
little more engaging you know
a little bit on facebook twitter no
comments you know that as as an
entrepreneur if you are going to be
helping me socialize my content I like
to see that you could do it yourself so
I'm not expecting massive engagement but
be good to see at least some comments
and a little bit more sharing so I have
a little more confidence that you could
do it for me if I wanted to do that but
otherwise it it looks nice you know it's
it's a great set just to even have your
blog updated because a lot of companies
don't moving on clients see what the
clients is all about again we see this
map I take it out I don't know how much
value the sides and to see that again
you're mostly only here in Missouri I
would probably eliminate this map
especially with it you know so high up
top it's great to see some of the the
lists of the websites that you've worked
with you might want to try to find a way
to categorize it so you know you've got
Sam seller I'm assuming that's some kind
of restaurant it looks like this is a
real estate agent you might want to
break it in two different categories so
that if I'm a real estate agent I can
quickly find the websites that you've
done for people in my industry and I
don't have to scroll through a whole
bunch of different sites know you've got
a church here if you're looking at
churches as it as a target market for
you they may come to this site and just
see you know restaurants real estate
agents say uh this isn't for me
meanwhile you do have a section for you
know a church client that young may
hopefully convince them to want to sign
up with you at least learn a little bit
more so I definitely try to find a way
to separate them if I click through on
here let's see what we get
so this is a Sam seller and it's great
again that this comes up on every page I
love that very short description not
super helpful it's great there's a link
to the site if I want it's not great
that your Facebook stuff is getting cut
off right again from a design point of
view if I'm hiring a web site designer I
want I want their website to look good
so you're probably not going to get a
lot of comments and likes anyone on
these pages so I probably take it off
and it doesn't look good to come to
these page and see that nobody's like
did or commented on it so I probably
removed that I would love to see what
was Sam's problem and why did he come to
you and what were the results study God
and maybe a picture his face with a
quick testimonial that would make me
want to potentially higher you know if I
had a bar / grill and and I had similar
problems with Sam when he told his story
and he says things like it's great
working with you know Jason and the team
and some of the specific results that he
got then I'd be much more inclined to
want to hire you compared to just seen
something like this so I spent a little
bit more time beef into beefing up the
portfolio is that something that people
are going to spend a lot of time looking
at so you've got three pictures here oh
great if I click on it what happens I
see the same picture and then the same
picture again and the same picture okay
slideshow great I mean you may not need
to have that you have little pictures
here anyway not a huge deal so I
definitely spend a lot more time though
on the on the individual clients page we
want to tell their story have a picture
of a testimonial try to show some kind
of results that they got by using you
and then if we click on the main clients
page here to break that down into
categories so I can quickly find
something thats related to my business
and see if it's going to be a fit for
what I do or not the last page here is
contact so I'm assuming the higher rest
goes to the same page
actually goes to a different page higher
let's see what's the difference okay so
higher just a contact form that's good
you may want to make this the 800 number
you know you don't necessarily have
people have to pay to call you and it's
a little bit of discrepancy here so I
just put that 800 number in there as
well let's go back to the contact page
last page here so it's great you kind of
see where you are email Jason so even
here put a little picture Jason like you
know even if just a one-man show with
Jason doing everything put your picture
there be great to see your smiling face
and you know it helps me connect you
just a little bit better make me more
likely to want to sign up with you
you've got here about the email
newsletter to receive updates I don't
know how many people are actually doing
this probably not a lot you want to show
something here too don't show them the
value that's gonna get from the
newsletter so give them some kind of
free bonus or offer or white paper or
show them an example what the newsletter
is going to be just so that they're more
likely to sign up because that's a lead
for you to be able to follow up on and
then let's look down at the bottom here
so what else we got feedback now this is
great I love modern web I recommend them
to anyone this should be much more
prominent and I'd love to see who said
that and you know what project they were
part of ideally a picture to this is
awesome that you have this this should
not be buried you want to make this fun
and center because this is going to help
again show that you're not just some
fly-by-night operation it's real
business you're real clients really
happy with you because a lot of people
do not like the website designer and had
terrible experiences with them so the
show that your professional organization
with great customers adds a lot of
credibility so this definitely should
not be buried at the bottom we already
talked about the newsletters it's great
you have the social media links again
down here on Twitter and Facebook will
load it up and again we look at our
twitter page the same thing there and
facebook facebook is going to the
facebook facebook
page which is interesting so your link
is broken here yeah if you look at the
bottom left hand corner you'll see it
goes to facebook.com / facebook which is
not going to be great from a web
designer point of view here probably
wouldn't want to hire somebody who has
internal links that are broken or
incorrect on their own page so something
you definitely fix up how about this one
this one too is a little off
facebook.com / facebook so definitely
fix those up so those are my initial
thoughts overall very professional but I
think you could do a lot more to show
that you're an established company you
have a lot to work with here you're in
the danger of being thrown with all the
other web development guys who haven't
really done anything and they just throw
up a website and hope they're going to
get some business and so as an
entrepreneur looking for a designer
that's the challenge is trying to figure
out who was actually a good company that
want to work worse versus everybody else
who might scam you out of my money so
hopefully that helps for those of you
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below i love seeing
those thumbs ups come in and also if you
have a thought about this website or one
of your own you could definitely leave a
comment underneath this video i always
read them and try to answer as many as i
can and if you have a you know review
that you want to get done with your
website is also the fiber gig that i'll
list the link below the video so thank
you and you'll see you on the next
episode
you